we're headed out to the middle of the
English Channel into the pitch-black on
the lookout for the no almost daily
stream of small migrant boats attempting
to reach the UK is flat calm it's a very
mild night so it's it's don't be around
this time when the market started
leaving the beach in France almost as
soon as dawn breaks over these busy
shipping lanes
the first migrant boat comes into view
we counted 13 on board some weaving and
shouting to us
[Music]
shadowing it the French patrol vessel
Aramis which had been with it since it
left a beach near Calais two hours
earlier and from what we could see was
making no attempt to intercept the boat
the border force vessel speed well
arrived on scene soon after the migrants
crossed into UK waters we can see the
French patrol boat Aramis circling the
area while the border force vessel speed
well is now down in front of the
migrants port they just got them to stop
their engines they're about to try to
get the migrants from that boat
transferred onto their vessel UK
authorities say their French partners
are as committed to stopping migrant
crossings as they are but those who know
these waters aren't as convinced be
honest that's not the first time I've
sitting there it's quite regular they
don't seem so interested in stopping the
vessels as they do so
escort them across this was one of seven
migrant boats intercepted during our
time in the channel Coast Guard
helicopters a spotter plane three border
force vessels and a lifeboat were all
involved we watched as dozens of men
women and children were taken to Dover
Harbour and checked over at a border
force processing centre the Home Office
told us their partnership with the
French was working that last weekend
alone they stopped a hundred migrants
from making the crossing but from what
we witnessed it's clear the efforts to
halt the boats once they've launched is
far less successful with migrants
determined to resist all efforts to
intercept them until they've achieved
their goal of reaching UK waters mark
white Sky News in the English Channel